yeah hi Rich
how you doing
yeah okay what do you got for me
all right so sorry no cam I'm in a
female dominated
career path so having my face in this
would be a death sentence
thank you and um
just
the concept of betaization through a
thousand concessions I completely
understand
but reversing it or turning it back onto
the woman
is that possible or would you just say
that's maintaining frame what do you
mean by turning it back onto the woman
like using the tactic of betaization
through a thousand concessions oh you're
talking about having her sort of simp
for you
yeah
um
interesting question let me contemplate
that for a sec so do men put women
through a process I guess falling head
over and heels in love with a guy might
be a similar sort of thing but I don't
think women's simp for guys
the way that I've seen men do it for
women
um so the answer to that would be no
it's similar but it's not the same like
many things with men and women you know
there's there's a lot of similarities
but there's also some pretty significant
differences so you're talking about
reversing it did you did you go through
this process like over the last year or
so with somebody that you're saying
oh um I was in a seven year on and off
relationship with a girl that was just
an absolute nightmare okay so I I've
reversed that it's a process that you
went through
uh
well it was in high school it was just a
bunch of like the standard dorky
stuff you know yeah
so yeah like to your point it is about
maintaining frame
um you don't look there's like a point
and no return
where it's like you know if you're
digging a hole it's actually easier to
keep digging to come out the other side
you know what I'm saying
um I think that for most guys by the
time they realize they've gone through
betaization through a thousand
concessions or it may be like concession
number 963.
you know what I mean
um that's when they reached the
realization like [ __ ] you know I I just
stamped everything yes for the last two
three years she's gotten used to the
fact that I say yes all the time
you know for most guys to be honest with
you I mean if you're at that point it's
it's easier to start fresh with a new
relationship where you can hold frame
from from the get-go if you've gone
through years of
yes honey yes whatever you want you know
we'll move here yes we'll renovate this
yes we'll go to this event and you just
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes you're just
stamping everything yes you're kind of
[ __ ] right because it's like what do
you do like one day you get up and you
go you know what I'm gonna say no for
once
she's gonna be like excuse me she's
gonna like you know she's not gonna take
it seriously you know what I'm saying
yeah I understand
if she sees you as a beta she's always
going to see you as a beta it's very
difficult to go from you know the beta
mindset the plugged in guy to the
unplugged Alpha sort of thing uh with
the same chick when she sees you as that
very difficult
um if anybody's ever done it I'd like to
hear about how you did it because I've
because I've not seen it
right okay and I have uh one more
question about if you agree with Rolo on
something okay
so
he said something to the effect of for
the guys that understand the red pill
and all that stuff like cool you can be
with friends with him but for everyone
that isn't or they're they fight it more
than like just using pure logic just
it's like reading rights or reading last
rights to the dying are you in agreement
of that you co-sign that
okay so I'm not sure I understand the
question so so if somebody's a plugged
in beta male foreign
yeah like does like would you say
there's a point where like you really
could bring them in or would you say
like it really is just based on what
trauma they experience you could show
them the light you can hand them a book
you can text them a link to a video that
that might start the process for them
but you know it's like we just talk with
um
uh what was his name there uh D.L Saint
you know he's you know you can lead a
horse with water but you can't make him
drink sometimes you can even shove them
in the water but they still won't drink
right
um for most guys
it's the trauma the chaos in their life
that brings them to a point where they
start using the Rational mind and they
stop saying things like I feel like and
they start using language like I think
and then they come to the Awakening and
they unplug from and they're like okay
now I need to go deeper down this Rabbit
Hole to see where it really goes to see
what else is there
so you know Rolo's got his own you know
opinions and way of uh seeing things and
you know uh we're not that different you
know when it comes to approaches I've
got some different ideas obviously and
um you know I do what works for me and
what I've seen works you know for the
thousands of guys that I work with so as
far as trying to unplug people I don't
think it's a good use of your time it's
like look you know you put a light on it
you're like hey look you know this is a
this is a GoPro battery you know you can
see it's a GoPro battery it's got all
the signs of a GoPro battery but if you
can't see that's a GoPro battery then
just put it down and walk away from it
and then just leave the guy alone
because he's because he's not going to
see it he's going to see whatever he
wants to see that's basically what it
boils down to right yeah and by the way
everyone rich is completely right once
you start hearing the I feel like it
will drive you absolutely up the wall I
work with it's just me and six other
women in my
my job basically and I hear I feel like
every 30 seconds and it makes me it's
awful yeah thank you sorry guys hate to
do it to you but you know this is just
part of the process
nominal all right thank you thanks buddy
and again guys if you've read the book
um do me a solid and head over to Amazon
and leave a quick review if you haven't
gotten it's available in print Kindle
and Audible and uh the follow-up to it
where I take you further down the rabbit
hole is going to be out before the end
of next year hey guys I really hope that
you enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational Essentials
for health immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment Below in this video
peace out